most people never think about when they
recruit a board member they think well i
need a ceo
or i need a cfo or i need a technology
expert or i need this or that
what are some of the things they never
think of they never ever
say well i need somebody that has a
great sense of humor
[Music]
wonderful dennis kagan thank you so much
for being on my show how are you
i'm good thank you michael how are you
wonderful where are you calling from
uh i'm in that a suburb of dallas texas
wonderful okay i'm actually going to
texas just in a few days to see my new
to see my brother's newborn uh so third
time uncle and i'm very very excited
in san antonio okay so uh so not too so
not too far but
what i'm very excited to talk to you in
these next 20 minutes or so
is the fact that you've been a part of i
think 67
boarded for-profit board of directors
mostly tech companies and
i don't think i met anybody who was on
67 boards
so uh so i'm very excited to talk in the
next 20 minutes about what it means to
be a board member and what is the role
of of board of the board of a for-profit
company but aside from that a
published author you know you're an
instructor in the in business school so
dennis i would love for you to just give
me a really brief intro to your journey
how do you get to be on 67 seats in tech
companies
well uh i started working for ibm in
1967.
and i hold some kind of a record i
worked for ibm for 366 days
exactly i quit one year of the day
when i started because i realized that
big company wasn't for me
but i was already sort of in the
computer industry obviously in the 60s
uh then i got a job selling com selling
computer time sharing
and i realized that the customers i was
trying to sell to didn't know what to do
with a computer
they liked the idea of time sharing but
they and remote computing but they
didn't know what to do
so two of my buddies who were engineers
and i started my first our first company
my first company
and it was a it was a remote access
computing application software company
and we started it in 1968
1968 for remote access computing
that's right application software that's
before the internet
yeah long before the internet
uh and uh so we and and i was an avid
reader i read the wall street journal
business week forbes and fortune not not
much else
so i knew if you had a company you were
supposed to have a board so we we had a
board
we created a board so that was my first
board and then every company i started
i've started about 18 or found it or
co-founded about 18 companies
mostly tech every single one after that
had a board
so by the time you know time passed
people that i was in business with knew
me as having a board so whenever they
thought about a board
the only person they knew that was on
one was me so i got a lot of questions
so i
that's how i got involved in one company
after another they said well
what does a board do and i would talk
about it and they said well will you
help me would you be on the board
and that's still happening today okay so
that's how you actually that's how you
get introduced to 67 different
uh different board positions but you
know you know when thinking a bit more
broadly about the the role of the board
of directors
that's not a controversial topic right i
mean as you know growing up as
a young entrepreneur now it's very it's
very natural for me to understand that
yeah every
group that wants to that has some
difficult decision-making processes
needs this other group who will oversee
it and
sort of strategically think what is the
best way to get from point a to point b
well yes but you're you seem to be a
step ahead
of most uh young entrepreneurs most of
them recognize well yeah i have a board
but me and my partner are fine we don't
need any other advice or we don't want
to get anybody involved because we're
afraid what if they get control and what
if we have to listen to them and there's
a lot of different arguments
and questions so they're not as educated
as you are the primary reason
to have there if you have a company you
have a board by default legally right
right maybe right but you've got one
okay
right if you if it's just you or just
insiders
you're getting the in the opinion and
the guidance of insiders employees and
family and whatnot
you get their guidance anyway they're
not bringing anything new to the party
the reason have a board is to expand the
perspective that you're getting
to include highly capable other people
that you respect
who can give you a different perspective
different
experience different context than you
already possessed to expand your
capability so it's like going out
and bringing on some other people who
are highly regarded in their fields
as consultants so to speak right if you
have a private company
people don't understand that the ceo
reports to the board if you're the board
then you report to yourself
okay right but if you if you have if
even if you were the only
person uh insider on a seven person
board and you had six other people on
the board
and they all voted against you if you
own controlling interest
you you just call a meeting and fire
them or you do whatever you want anyway
if you
owner the board reports to the owners
even though the ceo reports to the board
and a lot of people so but then it's you
know what i'm when i'm thinking about
this
it makes perfect sense but there must be
some conflict that
sometimes getting aboard too early
invested in the company and too many
different ideas and different
perspectives too early can actually be
detrimental
to your progress because you know in my
mind you're starting a company
as like you know in the earlier you are
the faster you have to move in order to
prove yourself into and to sort of break
things right
and having more people involved in the
decision making processes can just make
it more difficult
so is there a sweet spot from your
perspective on when it's the right time
to have
external people coming in with their
specialty and expertise
the the the issue that you're alluding
to
is really a factor of who those people
are
not whether you have them or not and so
at an early stage if you could afford to
hire
six of the top people in the country in
certain fields like sales
finance marketing manufacturing
software development whatever it is if
you could afford to hire six people like
that and you would
then why wouldn't you get those same
types of people
if not the same people to join the board
for a few stock options and get their
advice and their input get there because
isn't the board isn't the board much
longer term that you're saying
you're sort of committing to have this
person a part of your journey for many
years down blind well that's a good
that's a good question the board is not
a lifetime position
and companies companies particularly in
the early stage they tend to evolve
quickly
so you mean so you the best you might be
able to do is get somebody who used to
be a director of something at a big
company
but you grow a little and you gain a
little bit more experience and your
company becomes a little bit more
valuable so to speak
then you might be able to to approach
somebody that has
more experience is more accomplished
maybe what happens to that first person
because
you know what what happened you asked
you you cordially ask them to resign
you give them their stock options and
you move on you cycle through
breathing is that common is that common
to cycle through and ask
it's not common enough too many people
think well
i've committed to them i don't want to
get rid of hey now one mechanism that
that
most companies use to avoid that problem
is they have terms
like a one year board term or two year
board term or something like that okay
and so even if they don't like the
person they're they're
reticent to ask them to resign even in
a very cordial way so they well we'll
live with this person even though
they're disruptive and their advice
isn't any good anymore
because in a year and a half they'll be
off the board anyway no that's wrong
make arrangements for them to leave the
board
if they're not doing what you that's
fascinating
okay i don't think you know in all the
board discussions that i've had
around this about the strategy behind
structuring for a board and so on
and you know very rarely i hear about
this you know
what to do when you don't have a
successful board and what i'd love to
spend some time on with you dennis is to
to get sort of you know your to pick
your brain on your experiences and what
are some of the most you know successful
parts of the board and the least
successful parts of
of the board experience so that you know
i can learn from your personal
experiences well the best
the best part about the the best part of
the board is
that you receive first-class advice from
experienced
experts particularly in areas that you
may
not be as competent in or you may not
have other people
involved in your company that know a lot
about that
in the early days you may not be able to
afford a cfo
so having an experienced cfo gives you a
financial perspective
maybe you can't maybe there's nobody in
the company that has big time
ceo experience so having a part-time ceo
might give you the benefit so you're
receiving best-of-class advice
number two no one person can think of
everything
and so you get by by by getting together
with a capable group of board members
men and women and so forth
then you you're likely to get fresh
perspective
innovative ideas that you didn't already
think about
yourself like whoa i never thought of
that that particularly board members are
very good
at in one industry of saying well in my
business
when when we face problems we did this
and this and this and it might not be
common
in your business but they bring a
perspective of things in other
industries
in other countries or whatever that may
have worked well for them and it may
spark an idea
it really it's using the board as a
competitive advantage giving you an
in just an inside track uh
the next thing is that it can provide
very very impressive optics for
customers for vendors for investors
uh i've put people on the board that
that people said
how did you ever get a person like that
on the board of a startup that had no
revenue
i mean world renowned you know ceos
and four-star admirals and all kinds of
key i brought
i got i got the guy that had been
previously the director of the nsa
to join the board of a cyber security
software startup so
you don't know who you can get i've
gotten i recruited a guy
to one of my boards a number of years
ago like 15 16 years ago he's still on
the board
he had to retire because he reached the
a retirement age
so he had been on the board of general
motors raytheon
hewlett-packard and use electronics for
four years
and he was previously president of
caltech and
and he joined the board of a startup
for some stock options and he's still on
the board today he's not a startup
anymore but he's still on the board
today
his experience and connections were
invaluable
to the company and he's just one of a
number of board members
over the years you don't know who you
can get until you try it's an honor to
be asked even if you
even if it's not something that you
would consider for a variety of reasons
so it gives you
uh and then the if you're if you're
an early stage company and you're
completely controlled by insiders
whether it's a family business or
whether it's a tech startup and you've
got
one or two or three founders okay having
independent board members provides a
good buffer
between disagreements an independent
board member can radiate
issues between founders right right
whether they're family issues or founder
issues
and give some perspective like hey sam
you know
bill's got a good point there have you
considered this or this so that they can
soften the the kind of conflict that
founders
also often have so what i'm what i'm
what i'm hearing from this is that one
of the one
one so there's two really critical
lessons there one is that one of them is
to approach
not be afraid like shoot for the stars
approach the people even if they don't
have time they'll
they'll they'll be honored for asking
even if they were the previous president
of caltech
and worst case you'll get a no talk to
me later in a different time right
the second lesson here is that you want
to make sure that your
board members are as independent of a
relationship with you as possible
because they will then be able to
help you go and help mediate through
conflicts and even if
you and your co-founders are you know
the best co-workers in the world and you
get each other
conflicts are inevitable the decision
making will be difficult and having
somebody independent
will be very useful for those moments
where you know
emotions might kick in or there's really
the human disagreement over something
right
so i recruited once
the founder chairman and ceo
of one of the five largest tech
companies in the united states
to a board of people he didn't ever know
in a city that he wasn't in uh
but he was interested in their business
so he agreed to join the board
now he was the ceo and chairman of the
company
up until the time it went public
originally then he retired
but on a but on a growing tech company
where had some similarities to his
he regretted not staying with the
company
after it went public it's a very very
very famous company
he left when it went public but he never
took it from that point to where it is
now
so he regretted that so the opportunity
to join the board of company that might
have
were hit where his input might be
beneficial to get them to the next point
was just
a way that he could participate again
and and sort of contribute something
so you don't know you know you don't
have any idea the types of people you
can get now
it's it's a chance to interview somebody
even if they don't agree to join the
board and even if they don't want to
join your board they they're
the likelihood they're going to say you
know i can't do it for these reasons but
i know somebody else that might be
interested and then you get a
recommendation to them from this person
right no no definitely okay so you know
looking back at these you know
67 uh you know board positions what are
some of the key
things or key takeaways that you take
from from having a successful
group of board members i get why
specific individuals will be great for
for the company for the team but at the
end you know
when you think when i think of of a bor
part of a company i think of about you
know
seven eight people sitting around the
table and all each of them alone is a
superstar perhaps but
but but together they have to work
together to make some decisions right a
lot of the time there's voting decisions
so so what makes a successful group of
board members rather than an individual
well as i think you know uh uh
i in 2012 i thought you know
what is it that i know more about than
most people
i'm okay ceo i'm okay at this okay at
that but i'm not like the world's best
at this but what what can i claim
that i know as much more than anybody
about and it dawned on me this was in
that is private companies and boards of
directors
and so that's when i decided to write my
book which was published in 2012
the board of directors of a private
enterprise and
uh in that book there's there's a
chapter for example
there's a chapter on how to fire board
members
nope as you said nobody ever talks about
it but it tells you
how and why the fire board members and
how to do it
successfully there's also a chapter
about personalities
and and things that contribute to bad
boards
or good boards and that's where you're
going now so
for example in there i have a list of
things that
most people never think about when they
recruit a board member they think well i
need a ceo or i need a cfo
or i need a technology expert or i need
this or that
what are some of the things they never
think of they never ever
say well i need somebody that has a
great sense of humor
or they might think well i need somebody
that's collaborative
or i need somebody that can park their
ego
at the door right or you know if there's
personality traits
you're bringing a bunch of type a's to
the board you want to make sure that
they can
subjugate their own egos
and listen and focus their energies for
a reasonably
limited amount of time each month or
each quarter
on solving the problems of somebody else
and they need to be able to work
together
if they all have to jump up on their
soapbox and lecture each other
you know you can imagine if you got that
if you got five top ceos all in a room
not listening to each other but just
lecturing each other you're not going to
accomplish anything
so those people aren't suitable and what
i tell people is that they're
depending on what you need for your
board you should be filling
roles in the board that are important
things
for you but that you don't feel are
adequately represented within your
employees and within your
other you know close close associates
what what expertise don't they have but
then i'll tell people
there may be 10 people that are
qualified maybe 100 people that are
qualified
to fill that role in your board but
there may be only one or two that are
suitable
right qualified isn't suitable what's
that personality
how does it mesh with your culture
because the right board
would be listening giving their input
not repeating
one of my favorite things that that i've
learned from this one guy i mentioned
who had been on all those big boards is
that when when
when it come when the ceo says okay well
what do you think about this what do you
think about this what do you think about
this it goes to each board member
when it gets to this board member
if he doesn't have something different
to say
something that not has not been said
before he'll say
i agree with what she said and that's it
he doesn't have to get up on the chair
and say well i think and then repeat
what everybody else has already said
is that a common is that is that
something very common with boards that
you end up having
ego struggles rather than solving
natural problems yes particularly if
they haven't been put together by
somebody that has some experience or
some sensitivity
that can be very very common i uh one
time
uh i had spun a company out of another
company i found a ceo i set it up we
moved it to another location
later on that company's now was bought
uh about two years ago for about five or
six hundred million dollars
but when we brought in our when we
brought in our second round of venture
investors the first board meeting we had
with the new venture capital investors
uh we were standing around in the
boardroom with all the management and
board members and the previous investors
that were on the board
and this guy walked in and i was having
a conversation with the cfo at the time
and the and this new investor venture
capital investor walked in the room
and he walked around the room talking to
each group
shaking their hand and a very very
unusual body language
so the ceo so the cfo turns to me and
says what is he doing
and i said oh don't mind him he's just
urinating
in all four corners of the room so that
everybody knows who owns the company now
okay that's not going to be a productive
board member in this case they had no
choice he was the lead investor
however they also didn't do their proper
diligence
in selecting who was going to be that
investor to find out well who was going
to be on the board
and i've had ceos they said well i
prefer this venture
these two venture capital companies
because they know more about my business
where i told the ceo no they have a
history
of being interfering and not
collaborative even though
even though you think they know more i
would suggest these other two venture
capitalists
because they have a history of being
very supportive of founders
and management even in tough
circumstances and the ceo went with his
own
his own choice and within a year and a
half
they had taken the company away from
them they had booted them out
wow okay dennis i feel like i feel like
i'm in the middle of business school
here this is incredible and the lesson
that i'm taking from this here
is that you know at the end uh you know
if
you're you're building a company it's
your baby you're working so hard to make
it successful
some sometimes we get blinded by the
term sheets that we get or by the names
of the ventures and we
forget to do the real due diligence on
our due diligence on them
and understanding how are they going to
partner with us beyond the wiring of the
funds
to help us our burn rate how are they
how are they going to help us
you know ex make the expenses and and to
reach our milestones
and and it sounds like really the the
most the
most important way to do this is to
actually learn from their experience
not ask them how they are on board seats
but ask other people who they've been on
board
and i get their perspective because you
can't find the stuff on crunchbase you
can't find it on techcrunch right
this is all you know so one of the
things that i spend the most time doing
with early stage companies
is preparing their incorporation and
their governance processes
so that investors can't come in and get
control of the company
there's a number of things that can be
done early on
that can make it difficult for an even
if even if an investor gets
voting control there are things that can
be done earlier on
not at the last minute but earlier on
that can make it very difficult for them
to get voting control
beyond just getting 10 votes per share
or like in snapchat's case no votes for
any public shareholder there's
other more subtle things that can be
done but nobody tells the founders how
to do that
the idea you ask when do you bring on a
board you definitely bring on a board
before you bring on investors
that are going to want to be on the
board right you want to form the board
the way
it's best for you then you want to add
your
institutional investors to that board
many people say well i'll form a board
and i'll get a stock option plan as soon
as i get investors
that's too late because once you get
investors
they then have a say so as to who
and how many are on your board if you do
it the way that you want to do it first
and they join the board then they're
joining an existing board
it's a much different dynamic because
the favorite intercapital board is two
vcs and a founder
okay my favorite capital board
it optimally is seven board members
the founder five or six or two founders
five or six
outside a four or five outside demand
and then the venture capital joins a
board like that
and they don't dominate the company no
matter how no matter what their equity
and you've already and you've already
set the expectations in the culture for
the actual board meetings
they're not coming in and dictating how
they want dennis this was so enjoyable
thank you so much again for for your
generosity with your time and the
inspiration
before we leave i have to ask you for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
well i think that that that it comes
down to
first of all at heart going back to 1968
i'm an entrepreneur
yeah uh the second thing is that i'm
really
although my my major in college was
economics
i'm really a tech guy starting with ibm
and all the way through i'm really
favorably
inclined towards technology all kinds
but mostly i t related semiconductor
just a whole bunch of different stuff
and then lastly
uh particularly over the last number of
years governance
corporate governance has has really
captured most of my interest in most of
my time
including the book so it really would
really be those three things that would
highlight my there would be three
business words not necessarily personal
words
i love it dennis thank you very very
much i really appreciate your time and
effort i look forward to reading
and i look forward to reading the book
as i gear up to start my own company
later on and for my own board
for my own board members so also expect
another email to request some advice
from you
but thank you very very much stay safe
and stay healthy my pleasure michael
it's the board of directors of a private
enterprise and it's on amazon and barnes
and noble
wonderful thank you very much thank you
take care
you